ancient Sparta is famous above all for
its reputation as a military power its
most famous King Leonidas led the
fateful battle of thermopylae but one
thing that many people don't talk about
is the fact that he wasn't the only king
of Sparta it had two kings from two
different royal families who both held
equal power the question is why how did
Sparta come to have two kings and what
did they do
well the origins of the Spartan Dyer key
is debated and frankly not something
with a definitive answer
the Spartans believed that both their
royal dynasties the ickey ad in Europe
on today mum when King Aerys two demos
had twins nobody knew which one was
older and so the Spartans decided that
both should be king what many historians
believe is the most likely reason for
Sparta having two kings is that when the
city-state of Sparta was first founded
it was made up of the merger of smaller
settlements the rulers of the two
largest settlements came to an agreement
to have a dual monarchy which managed to
persist just like in ancient Crete of
course ask him why Sparta had two kings
isn't limited to asking where they came
from it also includes asking why they
kept this system for centuries and in
order to know why Sparta had two kings
you need to know how its political
system worked Sparta had what's called a
mixed Constitution it had an elected
chamber called the Apella from which the
gerousia or a Council of thirty elders
were selected which also included the
two kings whose positions were
hereditary yet despite there being kings
the most powerful people in Sparta were
the Air Force who were five people
elected from the entire population for a
one-year term and amongst the Air Force
there was often little disagreement
mostly because they all used their
position to get rich and destroy people
who didn't like them so what did spartan
kings actually do then that depends on
which Kings you're looking at and when
since over time Spartan Kings lost
certain rights and privileges and by the
time of the Persian War as they did to
things above all else they were
religious leaders and they led the army
whilst on campaign though Spartan Kings
had near absolute Authority which is why
Aristotle described them as being
hereditary generals at home though
spartan kings could do little except for
overseeing religious matters and voting
in the gerousia so why would Sparta keep
two kings then why not just have one or
even scrub the kings all together well
the reason the king stayed was largely
because of how politically weak they
were you see the Air Force were the only
ones with real power and if there was
only one king then that means that the
opposition to them could coalesce around
one man with two they only needed to
keep one on side and since the two
dynasties were often rivals for glory
and power that wasn't too hard
it also prevented one of them from
running the Army in thus becoming too
powerful this is why the f4 was made a
promise to uphold the dire key and would
prevent one dynasty from removing the
other had the Spartan Kings had more
power than frankly the system would have
collapsed earlier and when the dike he
came to an end it was replaced by a
monarchy in 210 BC sputter itself didn't
last much longer and in 192 BC it was
conquered and forever removed as an
independent state I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
but thanks to my patreon supporters whom
you can see on screen now and with an
extra special thanks to James
Bissonnette Ike Danny Maloney Colin
Castleman Marvin Castle Rob Waterhouse
Aaron the white Jordan long way Chris
wicker Gustav Swann Gareth Turner
Marcus arse nur Maggie pax Kowski David
Silverman spinning three plates
Spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Winston
k-word Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett the original cage Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappelle par shoe 19 and Mo